نتابع هذه الصور الان وصول الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان الى مقر التصويت في
اسكوبار حيث يصوت هناك في اسطنبول اذا
الصور مباشره
لوصول الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
يصافح الحضور في حي اسكودار حيث يصوت في
هذا المركز
الانتخابي في اسطنبول قبل ان يغادر الى
العاصمه انقره وهو تقليد للرئيس اردوغان
عاده يمضي الليالي الاخيره
اذا نشاهد هذه الصور تجمع يرحبون بوصول
الرئيس التركي الحالي رجب طيب اردوغان على
مركز التصويت في حي اسكودار حيث يصوت هذا
الحي يسكن فيه الرئيس التركي منذ ان سكن
في اسطنبول وتولى رئاسه البلديه رغم وجود
مقر رئاسي له ولكنه يفضل التواجد في هذا
الحي في حي اسكودار هناك ارتباط تاريخي
بينه وبين هذا الحي حي اسكوبار في اسطنبول
رغم ان في الجوله الاخيره هذا الحي
بالمناسبه لم يعطي كامل الاصوات لاردوغان
بل تفوق عليه منافسه كالاشجار اوغلو في
هذا الحي وان كان بنسبه بسيطه الرئيس
اردوغان يتبادر اطراف الحديث طبعا
حرم الرئيس اردوغان ترافقه في هذه الجوله
وفي تصويته في هذا المركز حسب ما نتابع في
هذه الصور المباشره التي تريدنا
عامر لافي يتواجد في
هذا المركز تحديدا في مركز اسكودار حيث
يتواجد عامر هل تسمعني
اذا الرئيس اردوغان يتحضر للادلاء بصوته
يجهز البطاقه التي سينتخب فيها
اذا كما نتابع الرئيس
وحرمه يتحضران للدخول الى
مركز الاقتراع
للتصويت في هذه الجوله الحاسمه في اسطنبول
التي ينتخب فيها احد عشر مليون ناخب تعتبر
خزانا انتخابيا مهما
مازال يصافح الحضور ويتوجه الان
الى غرفه الاقتراع
اجراءات طبيعيه روتينيه
سيعرف عن نفسه بالبطاقه الشخصيه من ثم
ياخذ ورقه الاقتراع ويتجه
الى المنطقه العازله للتصويت وثم يضع
تصويطه في الصندوق
اذا لمن يتابعنا الان هذا الرئيس الحالي
رجب طيب اردوغان يدخل الى مركز الاقتراع
في اسكودار
هذه الاثناء وصل كمال كريشتار اوغلو
الى مركز الاقتراع في انقره
مدرسه الارجنتين في انقره حيث يتلى بصوته
هناك نشاهد الان اذا في هذه الصوره رجب
طيب اردوغان يصوت في حي اسكودار بينما
يصوت كمال كالشتار اوغلو في مدرسه
الارجنتين في انقره هذه اللقطه التاريخيه
لماذا هي تاريخيه لان هذه اول مره بتاريخ
تركيا يتم جوله اعاده بين منافسين
متنافسين على منصب الرئيس التركي اذا
كمال كانت شهر اوغلو مرشح تحالف الشعب يضع
الان صوته في صندوقه الاقتراع في العاصمه
انقره بينما يتحضر الرئيس اردوغان ليقوم
بالمثل ايضا يصافح كمال كريستال اوكلو
المتواجدين في هذا المركز الانتخابي في
انقره بالمناسبه انقره ايضا اعطت اصواتها
لكمال اوغلو في المرحله او في الجوله
الاولى بفارق طفيف وكذلك الحال في اسطنبول
هذا هذه المحافظه المهمه اقتصاديا
وانتخابيا الان الرئيس اردوغان
بعد ان وضع صوته على الورقه وفي المغلف
خلف العازل يتجه الان الى صندوقه الاقتراع
ليضع صوته في الصندوق بعد ان فعل هذا
بالفعل كمال اوكلو منافسه
الذي الان يتبادل اطراف الحديث
اذا الرئيس اردوغان يضع صوته الان
وحرمه ايضا تضع صوتها في هذه الصندوق
الانتخابي في حي اسكوبار الذي يقطن فيه
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان يوقع بانه فعلا
اتم عمليه التصويت
وكذلك تفعل حرمه
قبل ان يتوجه الى العاصمه انقره
يغادر الان
بنفس الوقت كمال كاليشتار اوغلو
زعيم حزب الشعب الجمهوري مرشح تحالف الشعب
المعارض
غرفه التصويت
بينما لا يزال الرئيس اردوغان داخل هذه
الغرفه
ويتحضر ايضا
للخروج لا ندري اذا مكنا سنسمع تصاريح
لكلا المرشحين الرئيس الحالي رجب طيب
اردوغان
ومرشح تحالف الشعب المعارض كمال كلتشتار
اوغلو سنواكب معكم طبعا هذه اللحظات
التاريخيه من عمر الجمهوريه التركيه وهي
تتحضر
للولوج الى مئويه ثانيه اذا الرئيس
اردوغان
تاريخي الديمقراطي التركيه حيث اننا نشهد
جولتين من الانتخابات وكانت الجوله الاولى
كما تعلمون فيه 14 مايو والان في 28 مايو
نقوم باجراء الجوله الثانيه ولا تدخل
الاحزاب في هذا السباق وليست هناك قائمه
لائحه طويله
للمرشحين بل بقي هناك مرشحان اثنان فقط
والشعب هو من
سيصوت لاحد المرشحين واعتقد ان عمليه
الفرس ستكون سريعه جدا اليوم
ولا شك
في تاريخ الديمقراطيه التركيه امر مهم
لاننا نرى انتخابات من هذا القبيل
لمنصب الرئاسه لاول مره ثم ايضا المشاركه
بحوالي 90 بالمئه تعتبر نموذجيه في العالم
لان تركيا قد
اكدت على مدى تمسكها بالديمقراطيه من خلال
مشاركه المواطنين بنسبه 90 بالمئه تقريبا
هذا ما رايناه في الجوله الاولى وهذا ما
سنشهده اعتقد في الجوله الثانيه واتمنى ان
تكون النتائج عائده بالخير على تركيا
ونحن دائما نناشد بالناخبين بعدم التراخي
ونناشدهم بالتمسك بخيارهم الديمقراطي
بالتوجه الى صناديق الاقتراع طاب يومكم
[موسيقى]